no oh hold the door
i can't really look
[Music]
that's a great way to start it
[Music]
the first seven seasons of game of
thrones were filled with lots of
death drama deception and of course
dragons
ahead of the final season we're going to
count down some of the most memorable
moments from the show
warning spoilers are coming
one of danny's defining moments is when
she kills the slave masters at astapor
basically daenerys trades drogon her
dragon
to him in return for freeing all of the
unsullied
danny is just constantly underestimated
and especially by men
there's this great reveal when she shows
that she actually has been understanding
him the whole time
i also like the detail of like she's
wearing the same cape that all the slave
masters do but she has one shoulder
overturned which is kind of like
the sign that she's about to flip
everything on its head
and the dragon burns the head slave
master guy
she's so legal so in charge so powerful
this is a really like quintessential
moment
of the way that dany approaches justice
and the way that she's going to rule
moving forward
cersei's been a villain throughout the
entire show and this is the first moment
where you really
feel a lot of sympathy for her so she's
been held captive by the phase of the
seven for a little while the high
sparrow forces her to do this
walk of atonement so he strips her naked
cuts off all of her hair and has her
walk from the sept of bailor
back to the red key she's been pretty
ruthless up until this point
um so you don't feel that bad for her
but you do
and they ring this bell and i was going
shame shame
shame shame shame shame shame
shame shame it's just so
gross and like dehumanizing
inside she's just like plotting the
things that she's going to do
to avenge this whole thing
in an epic cliffhanger jon snow was
murdered
in game of thrones yeah anyone can die
but they can also come back to life
i mean jon snow's resurrection had so
much build up to it
you could say it was shocking but i feel
like everyone knew this was coming
ghost wakes up and notices that he's
about to come to life
that's like such an iconic moment seeing
kitt harrington
opened his eyes and gasped was just like
oh
finally and everyone could all breathe a
sigh of relief that jon snow was
alive i wish
i was the monster you think i am tyrion
is
on trial uh for killing joffrey
and we the audience all know that he
didn't have anything to do with it
he like goes off on his whole family
which is really satisfying to watch
this was amazing it was just this
passionate speech
and this is when he demands the trial by
combat bearded tyrion is my favorite
tyrion this is when he like starts going
through his like dark phase
it's just peter dinklage showing why
he's won multiple
emmys for this show and it's also one of
the best written moments in the show
it's an amazing
monologue i did not kill joffrey
but i wish that i had peter dinklage
deserves every enemy he got nobody's
dying there's no big war
it's just a camera focused on
a masterful actor
[Music]
the purple wedding is the antidote to
the red wedding
this is when joffrey is getting married
to marjory tyrell
and then joffrey's tormenting tyrion as
he loves to do
and he winds up being poisoned and dying
and
it's supposed to be a mystery as to who
actually poisoned him
weddings never turn out to be happy
occasions
if you're getting married in westeros
maybe reconsider
to watch him choke literally is one of
the most
satisfying moments in this entire series
because he sucks
for a poison death it's like a really
gruesome death scene it's like eyes are
bleeding
he was such a little brat he definitely
deserves to die i love olynyk she's like
help the poor boy somebody
oh brutal i do not care about cersei's
tears
ugh
[Music]
loot train attack is one of the best
scenes in the entire show daenerys like
really becomes part of like what's
happening in westeros
brian and jamie are just sitting there
looking on like what is happening
and you just kind of hear like the
hooves
of the dothraki's horses as they're
approaching
[Music]
and then they come over the hill and
then all hell breaks loose
there does not prepare for this dragon
at all and i love it
they just come flying in burn the
soldiers
burn the wagons and it makes you feel
kind of
terrible about the lannister soldiers
being burned alive and just completely
decimated that dragon is huge now
the face everybody makes when they see a
dragon for the first time in the show is
always so good
there were real stuntmen on fire in this
scene too it's like watching a scene
straight out of hell
it just shows how powerful daenerys and
her army really are
[Music]
so this is hard home this is one of the
most famous battles from the
entire show it was this moment when
both book readers and show watchers were
able to kind of experience something
fresh together for the first time and it
was amazing
so at heart home jon snow is with the
wildlings and
the knights watch and the night king
and his army show up this was sort of
the night king's coming out party
it's also the first time that we
prominently see the night king
in action we had only really gotten like
a little glimpse of him at the end of an
episode before
basically like the night king and jon
snow just have this like
really intense face off like the way
they look at each other is just like
the most famous moment from this is we
just see the night king
standing there and lift his arms up
and you just get like goosebumps down
your spine
i didn't realize how slow this movement
was he's taking his sweet time
and also we learned that valyrian steel
kills white walkers
that was so cool
battle of blackwater was really the
first time that the show was able to
flex their budgetary muscles stannis
troops are coming up against king's
landing
but tyrion smart as ever um has a plan
it just shows how great tyrion is
that he thought of this it's like
watching a nuclear bomb
go off the way that everybody reacts to
it
and it's just green flames everywhere
you're not like
rooting for a particular side
necessarily like you care about people
on both sides
yeah stannis had no idea what he was up
against braun is invincible
he's never gonna die
the battle of the bastards is one of the
best battle scenes in game of thrones
it was just one of the most like
beautifully
shot and directed sequences that was so
visceral
jon snow leads an entire army to retake
winterfell from ramsay bolton
he is just disgusting and sick and
psychotic you also have this amazing
moment where jon snow
just takes off his belt holds up his
sword
and ramsay's entire army is charging at
him and he's just like bring it
it has a epic and cinematic quality to
it it's probably my favorite scene in
the whole show
he's about to take out all the horses
with one swoop
kit harrington was like actually there
with all those horses charging right at
him
oh yeah this is the moment where you
feel like jon could truly be king
iconic absolutely iconic oh
my gosh this is like one of the best
things i've ever seen on television
and ramsay is finally toast i mean it's
sad because of rickon and everything but
he should have zigzag so that's really
his fault
[Music]
[Applause]
tyrion has been accused of murdering
joffrey
and he calls for a trial by combat
oberyn martell
versus gregor the mountain clicking you
saw oberyn he was winning he was beating
the mountain
and then all of a sudden things take a
turn
punches out his teeth which is so gnarly
and then just squeezes his head
until it explodes and you honestly
thought oberyn was going to win that
fight until the very end
it is a shocking horrifying moment even
for a show that
is full of horrifying moments this might
be the worst everybody kind of looks
away or looks down after it happens
except cersei
honestly i can't watch it still to this
day if i see it i have to turn away it's
pretty gross
[Music]
yeah that that's everyone's face
i can't really look oh my gosh
i remember i couldn't sleep for that
entire night i couldn't stop thinking
about it
it was just the worst way
i've ever seen someone die on screen
[Music]
septa baler explosion was how cersei
killed a lot of her enemies
i think from the very beginning you knew
that something different was happening
and it had to do with the score because
ramin jawedi who
does all the music for game of thrones
he had he had intentionally never used
piano before
in any of the scenes this is really one
of the best scenes in the entire show
like the music
is chilling cersei um blows up the
church
uh using a whole lot of wildfire
the only thing that made me mad about
this is that marjorie was intercept i
love
marjorie ty rel r.i.p marjorie
she was great margaret was right always
listen to women
we'll never have a better game of
thrones scene than this
the pacing and the build up of that was
just so masterful
the high sparrow she got marjorie tyrell
she got loris tyrell
that's so she just murdered so many
people
that person didn't do anything yes
cersei look on she does not give a
f that is the most giftable moment of
the entire show just absolutely
iconic this is cersei's version of
self-care
hodor hold the door hodor
hold the door it's so hard to explain
bran and mira
are trying to escape they're leaving
hodor behind
and he's trying to hold the door against
all of the white walkers
it was like really confusing because
it's like we're seeing two hodors at
once we're like learning a lot about
hodor and then he dies
bran kind of goes into hodor's head bran
accidentally warged him into his
child self and he witnessed his own
death
during which mira reed was yelling at
him to hold the doors
and it's almost like he's having a
seizure in the past i just kind of
remember when i first watched this my
mouth was a gape
so messed up oh when you hear hold the
door this gives me chills
he had one job and he did it so well
to his credit he does hold that door for
a really long time
hodor hodor hold the door
this was um a character i really didn't
want to see go
he really got a good send-off and a
really deserving
send-off and he got to die with honor
you know that a lot of the people in
this show are going to die and you just
have to accept that going into it
leading up to the first season everybody
thought that ned stark
was the protagonist of this series that
he was going to be the person that we
were following across
this big epic fantasy tale so george rr
martin kills off
the main character in the first season
of the show so i
could not believe that they killed him
off so early you know it sets up the war
it sets up
everything med was really that very
first moment that people realized like
oh
this is not the show i thought i was
watching
it's actually way cooler basically
everyone's on the chopping block
literally i think this is like the first
time we really
see how ruthless joffrey is and then
sir ellen bring me his head just
up ends everything so we think here that
maybe ned stark is about to be
spared some mercy from joffrey but
instead joffrey decides to go
off with his head that is a giant sword
wow arya looks so young
oh they really like show his head coming
off
poor dead ned is no more also the crowd
could you just hush a bit
like come on
[Music]
oh the red wedding i had read the books
so i knew it was coming the red wedding
is one of those moments in the show
that everyone knows even if you don't
watch the show
the red wedding happened as kind of like
an attempt to repair
the relationship between the starks and
the phrase at first it seems like it's
going surprisingly well
when it started it's it was just like
your
stomach just drops as soon as catelyn
hears
the reigns of castamere start to play
and the entire tone just shifted
it is like the bloodiest thing
ever it's really shocking it's so gory
killed
catalin stark killed rob stark uh killed
his direwolf
oh this is the worst oh and killing
killing oh my god they're just getting
massacred they don't call it the red
wedding for no reason
they should have seen it coming like
walder frey is crazy supposed to be a
big happy
joyous event it was it was brutal
there's no other word for it just brutal
i would just like to say that from
season one the people in king's landing
totally suck all they do is like ask for
blood and like beg for blood
i'm like could you all calm down and be
civilized